yeah welcome to this video playing bacon
butty from the UK probably we gotta tell
rush variation of the French with a 6
and 9 f 6 yeah all kinds of weird moves
nowadays in the French and this intense
a quick g5i castle he will go g5 yeah is
there some other possibility maybe just
just try for this not sure if it's
really am doing me anything good but
just try something else ok maybe Queen B
6 now hmm I seem so I'm putting some
pressure on deform but maybe I can keep
it simple just take on the on before
yeah he can take on d3 but is this a
problem yeah I can also try to keep this
bishop why not actually and then night
g3 and short castles I think we before
was better actually just scream before
Queen d2 an exchange trying to play this
some somewhat simplified position with
Queens off with Queens off you don't
really feel them the lack of space so
much yeah okay so Queen d2 is playing
Queen before anyway now but I don't have
a great possible team
I mean something else great alternative
to G 302 III probably him don't know his
exchanging
yeah that's quite quite ok for black
don't really want to play a three but
what exactly you should I play maybe
this one threatening 93 & provo game to
take now Knight c3 as a threat which
ignores ok I thought it was a threat
positionally I mean not technically so
we should be three this is necessary to
also use the H poem
yeah of course the special ballistics
prevents me from canceling short but I'm
not sure that I that I need this can
play rook age 44 yeah maybe you can
initiate some see foul play but they
don't see it at the moment are this one
as you put a very very stupid row gauge
form again the problem is when a move
like 92s got night before
hmm
excellent alright simply you don't have
another may I need to play this there's
no other move yeah yeah this is actually
yeah I don't I don't get to get it I was
in trouble now I know I'm better again
in this end game not much but some what
he needed to keep pieces on the board of
course
on the way to c3 attacking a form f6 sf6
expected f5 is strange fixing the pawns
hmm
96 m is a threaten cannot play books
afore i just take and play play 96
ideas to invade oopsie eight Jack
check yeah it's a bit risky to to
continue here but check check check
don't want to draw I mean I'm really
clearly better check maybe I don't have
a win that's possible Jack yeah with 20
seconds sing better draw that but then
how do I win I don't I really thought
he's his team that's the team with the
sea fowl invasion but the computer
doesn't agree can I day 6 is the win
okay night a six yeah 9 a-6 I this is
much stronger hmm okay I've had I was so
so much done long time as so often but
this is much stronger attending the
night en he simply has no who's he can
take here not this can take on see one
would see one and now where do you go
and this is the key move basically
forcing him to take and then you get all
the pawns very easy I played a number of
really weird moves f5 was very bad for
for starters and and hereafter here you
need to play something else not before
is this really a is really helping me
maybe a move like f6 of
something or a four I don't know this
this is just helping me to simplify and
coordinate the position here what is
already am slightly better again it's
not substantial but it's it's it's in
it's something and after this year with
f5 it it's gettin it's gettin from the
magic yeah this special night a 60m yeah
but okay the timing plays a role as well
yeah my book edge for was exceptionally
exceptionally bad the idea is ok but
it's simply not working um young but ok
is probably around round equal to the
solution with the with the bishop on a
six preventing my castling andrew cage
for not working this is was what i was
thinking that he's got nothing on the
queenside and i'm playing whoo gauge 4g
for that I didn't see Quincy for ya
thanks for watching